welcome to this video playing j'adoube
first from France going form and
Sicilian again for white with white like
a change of change of structure once in
a while playing the classical dragon
though not the rouser variation would
have three I just don't know it too well
and prefer this kind of positional
approach let's see I'd like to play 95
now he's preventing that by pressurizing
c2 mmm yeah should I go to each voice
can be an offside piece still g4s and a
g5 is a move that not everybody likes to
play he does
interesting and very quickly played this
is a move that runs it till night a4 b6
for example but he has some counter play
rook a form is also a move but this can
be answered by at least 90 x e 2 nite c
to quincy to quit excel form nice tactic
hmm complicated complicated maybe I need
to get this night back into the game if
I get the bishop yet would be helpful
and if he goes to sea for i have 9 f 5m
wow that's an ambitious move
does he want to get a 510 K come on I'll
take I take this and now reconsider
maybe look a 4 here checking this
annoying night just thinking if it
retreats out to a cabaret five god this
is really this is really happening the
sponsor is gone how do I protect it
Queen a one looks completely ridiculous
maybe what can I do yeah maybe i can go
f3 and before f2 attacking the rook now
right 95 though i should have considered
this one at least considered it i can
maybe takes it too but still
no okay 94 looks like a very loose move
with bishop at two coming the night is
not really securely placed but I have
very strange pieces on a one and A four
hmm okay
not bishops III okay maybe I need to
return this look a three-hit key at
before and if he takes the check with
the pawn that should be it should be
okay for me he's got um he still got to
some some weak points in that I maybe
can exploit my queen is very far off
from them from the King side though
10 a queen III I take here b3 take on
his seven
maybe you can clear III and ignore it
maybe just take it right might be three
maybe I need to get out of this this
bloody pin maybe get rid of this pawn
this would really help Roxy to look
before now just try to keep it okay
Jeff 48 seconds against two minutes this
is my my blitz games in a nutshell
trying kingi to Bishop d3 activate the
bishop 95 has a move maybe yeah yeah
I'll take that I really need to get rid
of this so the spawn check
23 seconds time warning at least I'm
getting a real car black resign no
that's nice 20 seconds I probably would
have would have managed but still I had
heck could have taken it before but okay
this was hanging still I didn't the only
side now yeah very very strange game
around here this is amazing chicken this
is in fact playable the way I can go
here something like that but is this
really better than the game I don't know
maybe I don't know but this at least
looks like a somewhat okay structure
this is this is entirely unclear though
this probably not but I I was really
fearing the spawn I mean and this is why
I didn't take here okay okay my computer
points out see form Wow yeah this is
very cold-blooded very cool blood move
this one there are Queen takes i take
the night and rook takes i have a check
here and require seven while they are
very difficult very difficult yeah it
was just um justified here check yeah
hard to play with 20 seconds so I got
got a bit lucky here thanks for watching